34 minutes after the hour the d.a in
albany new york announcing that
disgraced former governor andrew cuomo
will not repeat will not be charged in
the groping scandal and the manhattan
da's office is also shutting down its
probe into the nursing home coveted
death circumstance without charging
cuomo in that case either todd
janis dean whose in-laws died of covid
in a new york nursing home back in 2020
says these victims deserve justice and
she won't stop fighting jd joins us now
janice why do you think these probes
were closed
i think there were deals made
i thought about this last night i
thought why was it so easy for governor
cuomo to just resign in august mr tough
guy i'm never going to resign you know i
didn't do anything wrong and then i
thought to myself last night it's
because i think he cut some deals he was
going to be impeached there's no
question about that and i think
lawmakers said listen if you resign
in the new year we're going to start
dropping these cases so eventually you
can run again
long-term care resident coveted deaths
through january the 19th of 2021
unbelievable actual deaths more than 12
000 cuomo by the way reported right
around 8 500 and here's the real
situation
cuomo's lawyer is saying listen as we've
said all along there was no evidence to
suggest that any laws were broken
but you have to wonder janice if if not
laws broken
you lied about the circumstance and this
is a public health emergency it just
i feel for your loss but i think i'm
like a lot of people i'm completely
frustrated that it doesn't seem like
anything ever happens
well listen there are still
investigations into the nursing home
massacre
the attorney general here in new york
there's an investigation that with that
the fbi is also investigating the
nursing homes as well as his 5.2 million
dollar book deal which i believe is the
crime he covered up all of those numbers
at least 50 percent of deaths in nursing
homes to sell his 5.2 million dollar
book that is to profit for himself and
that is all that's against the law so i
i do think that there will be charges
against him it just won't be by the
new york da's offices which by the way
i'm going to start phone calling today
because i do believe they made a
deal with the devil
before he left office and they need to
hear from us
you know our voices should be heard
what was your reaction jd when you first
heard this news
disappointment you know uh obviously
disappointment on behalf of the 15 000
loved ones that don't have a voice
anymore but disappointment for all of
the brave women that came forward to
talk about his disgusting abusive
behavior you know this is about abuse of
power whether you're talking about the
nursing homes whether you're talking
about his hands on his aides whether
you're talking about him
using his resources his state resources
to give out friends and family kova
tests and write a 5.2 million dollar
book to benefit himself it's all about
abuse of power and i believe he is the
most corrupt governor in new york state
history and we can't let him forget that
you can read janice's new op-ed out this
morning just dropped at 5 a.m on
foxnews.com
janice the fight continues we thought
you thought it was over but it
definitely continues and we appreciate
what you're doing
thank you so much
thank you guys hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now